[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter
good day young friend how are you doing
today ah
i'm doing very well actually i'm still
going strong
in spite of everything that's happening
in the world
because we have a
outlook from where we're going and where
we're heading okay
let's open with a word of prayer
our heavenly father thank you so much
for bringing us again
together
so that we can discuss
important events can you please bless us
and also enlighten our minds in jesus
name amen
amen
martin
when we get to heaven one day
how long will it take before we get a
glimmer of understanding as to what this
great controversy was all about
i think it's going to take a few years
about a thousand yeah
it could take a thousand years yes
and uh
the thing is so deep
and
the rabbit hole
[Music]
is so incredibly steep on a downward
trend all the way down
that it'll be impossible to unravel it
all
until we have
vision that isn't through a glass darkly
yes
so today we want to talk about
quite a few issues
and some people will
again think
conspiratorial
i love that word
yes i see it in all the government
documents now as well yes as they are
being proclaimed through the media
so
let us talk about some of the issues and
let's make it quite plain
we do not know all the answers
we are not
sages no
but uh there certainly are very many
interesting things going on in the world
and when you look at the legal aspects
and the religious aspects and all of
these
there is
such a complicated neck network that has
been strung together
that it will take a thousand years to
just
try to unravel it so by no means
are we going to
uh say that
we have nailed it now
but
we just want to chat and conjecture
and give our anti-conspiracy
people
something to talk about and we have to
keep them happy too right so
yes because what else are they going to
do yeah what else they're going to do
yes so we have to give them something to
chew on
but even if it is not so even if it is
so it's interesting to talk about these
things so today we're going to talk
about the great reset
a long time coming
and what is a long time
is it a year is it two years is it ten
years is it uh maybe a hundred years is
it a millennium is it is it uh six
millennia
we won't go any further than that
so yes let's talk about some of the
issues and
i don't know how long it's going to take
but if it takes too long we'll split it
if it doesn't then fine and we'll
we'll just leave it where it is
so
let's start with a few
questions
galatians chapter 4 16 says
am i therefore become your enemy because
i tell you the truth
that's such an interesting
statement there by paul
so as if to say so you don't like what
i'm saying to you soon i am your enemy
yes what if it's the truth right exactly
are we so afraid of truth or are we so
indoctrinated that we cannot think
outside the box
so let's invite everyone to sit back
relax a little bit
and just speculate because you know
life is more than just what you see in
black and white right exactly yes there
are shades of grey too right let's go
into the shades of grey
now here's a very interesting verse in
the bible or a little story in the bible
matthew chapter 17 from verse 24.
and when they were come to capernaum
they that received tribute money came to
peter and said does not eye master pay
tribute
so this has to do with tax right
he says yes
and when he was come into the house
jesus
prevented him a very interesting
interesting thing there
so
peter was convinced one way yeah and
jesus said
it's not quite like that my friend let
me just enlighten you a little bit
saying what think is thou simon
and and that's exactly what we're gonna
do we're gonna ask some questions what
thinkers though
exactly is it like this or is it like
that you know just
nudge you in a direction but not being
dogmatic about it so jesus does the same
thing and he says what thinkers thou
simon
of whom do the kings of the earth take
custom or tribute
of their own children or of strangers
and peter said unto him of strangers
and jesus said unto him
then are the children free
that is a fascinating statement right
yes
so let's just stop it right there
so
according to the scripture and according
to the ancient custom which was
absolutely actually in harmony with
scripture because the scripture says i
may not take tribute
or
usury from a brother right yes
so
these these tributes were paid by
strangers or conquered nations
but the the citizens
were free men
we have an interesting group of people
in the world that call themselves
free
masons masons but leave that
let's not go there
all right so then the children are free
is it still like that today or does
everybody pay do you pay tax in your
country yes yes now if you go against
that system you get into big trouble and
there have been evangelists who have
tried to make the point according to
these verses
that you don't have to and they ended up
in jail right
okay so let's be very careful how we do
this this is just a friendly discussion
so then the children are free so a free
child or free man
is
not
compelled to pay any of these things
but then jesus has this fascinating word
notwithstanding
in spite of that
in spite of the fact that you are free
lest we should offend them
go thee to the sea and cast the hook and
take up the fish that first cometh up
and when they asked opened his mouth i
shall find a piece of money that take
and give unto them for me
and thee
now we've mentioned this verse before
but it's
it's
nice to go a little bit deeper
so who actually paid the tribute here
now
jesus jesus paid the tribute did he have
to no
no but notwithstanding the fact that he
didn't have to he did he did
why
not to offend so that they wouldn't be
offended
so
the irs or your government would they be
offended if you didn't pay taxes yeah
exceedingly so so unless they be
offended
let's pay them their taxes who's going
to enable you to pay those taxes jesus
god he gives you the ability to work he
gives you all of these abilities
so notwithstanding that it is not lawful
he's going to do it
but it's legal
because they've made it legal now
there's a difference between lawful and
legal
you'll have to explain that for us yes
we'll have to explain that there's a
difference between legal everything that
is legal is not necessarily lawful
so how does that work
if you define something
as legal and people swallow it
well then you have set the precedent and
the situation stands
now
a question we said we're going to ask
some questions
um
does satan
love god's law
no
he hates it right yes with a passion
would he try to undermine the law yeah
yes
now something like that can be pretty
blatant and pretty obvious
so how about if you do something that's
legal but not lawful
then it will appear as if you are
in harmony with the law when in fact you
are against the law
can you do that on a religious level yes
can you have an appearance of godliness
denying the power thereof yes
all right so that's his religion
that's exactly that's satan's religion
and that's satan's economy satan's
religion is it appears
legal legal but it's not lawful but it's
not lawful that's his religion and that
is how he operates
so everything has to appear to be
in harmony and correct
but in actual fact it's a lie
that's how i work yeah okay now that
we've said that
and i'm not saying to you people don't
pay your taxes
i'm not saying that at all
i'm saying notwithstanding the fact
that it is not lawful but legal
pay your taxes lest they be offended
unless they put you in jail
all right now i haven't gotten that off
our back let's continue
there are a couple of role players at
the end of time
revelation chapter 13 let's go just
through some verses and the beast
which i saw was like unto a leopard and
his feet were as the feet of a bear and
his mouth as the mouth of the lion and
the dragon gave him his power and his
seat in great authority
okay now this beast
has always been identified as the roman
catholic system
which in fact got its power from the
dragon yes satan in a
physical sense it was rome
because the symbol of rome is the dragon
you go to any roman bridge you'll have
the dragon there yes all right as a
symbol so rome gave him his power but
the dragon really is also according to
revelation chapter 12
satan
so just like the the prince of persia
and he's the one behind the power right
okay
so you we know who the beast is and we
know that he has greek
components leopard components
that he has medo-persian components and
that he has the mouth of a lion he has
babylonian components
and revelation 13 verse 4 says they
worship the dragon
which is satan
which gave power unto the beast and they
worshipped the beast saying who's like
unto the beast who is able to make war
with him
so
the dragon is the one that works through
the
system and basically you can say they
are like father
and son
now this beast system is the false son
yes
everybody has to bow down and worship
him yes
he is a god on earth yes he is the
mediator whereas christ is the mediator
he forgives your sins whereas only god
can forgive your sins and christ forgave
sins he said your sins are forgiven
so he's taking all the prerogatives of
christ upon himself
then he had a mortal wound jesus had a
mortal wound in 1929 he had a
resurrection because the wound was
restored he got his kingdom back the
vatican right
so he's playing the role of the false
son now there's a third component to
babylon which is the false prophet which
is then the false holy spirit exactly
revelation 13 verse 12 says and he the
second beast now the one with the
lamb-like horns that we haven't got on
the screen here
exercises all the power of the first
beast before him so he becomes
prescriptive in terms of
legal issues in terms of
moral issues moral issues ecclesiastical
issues so he becomes a power like the
first beast
which not only dictated the law to kings
because the divine sword stood higher
than the secular sword right
but he also
dictated morality and ecclesiastics
okay
so the second beast will do the same
that's the time we are living in now
and he the second beast will force the
world
and everyone dwelling on it to worship
the first peace to pay it homage
now how do you pay someone homage by
obeying him yeah honoring what he
dictates okay so when he says to you
what you must do and you do it you are
paying him homage and if he says you
must do a and god says you must do b if
you do a you are worshiping the first
beast correct right or you're worshiping
the beast yeah
okay
whose deadly wound was healed now the
deadly wound took away the secular power
of the roman catholic church
and he also had no power over his
separated children
but this system according to the bible
say i will not suffer loss of children
my children will return to me
and so she started the economical
council
to herd the children back into the fold
and this year 2021
is going to be a very special ecumenical
year
because they will commemorate in this
the
ex-communication of martin luther
and then reconcile
[Music]
and the children will be happily back in
the fold having signed the joint
declaration on justification which is
not a justification declaration at all
but the council of trent declaration
so
finely worded
that
even the protestants are willing to
overlook the flaws yes
okay so we've established that
so we're going to see a resurrection of
the first beast and we're going to see
it come back into power
and
that will happen with
stealth and with deceit
and with lies
so that humanity can be fooled into
giving up the truth and accepting the
lie
and it will seem
lawful it will seem legal legal sorry
i'm still getting that one right it will
be illegal it will be it will be it will
be illegal but it won't be lawful
we have to get into that right
revelation chapter 13 tells us how they
will do this by deceit
the bible says so it's not rocket
science yeah
like you said earlier the only way you
can
like make it seem
legal
if you have the law
is to have the seat
because otherwise you have to have the
seat because otherwise you'll see the
law as the right one you have to have
the seat of power
and you have to worship the beast so it
must seem lawful
but it's actually not lawful it's only
legal yeah and the only way that you can
get away with that is with the seat yes
all right so it deceivers them that
dwell on the earth by means of those
miracles which he had power to do in the
sight of the beast saying to them that
dwell on the earth that they shall make
an image to the beast which had the
wound by the by a sword and did live
all right so the second system will be
like the first it will be an image
it will appear to be the same thing
church and state dictating morality
and
governmental issues and economics
verse 15 says and he had power to give
life unto the image of the beast that
the image of the beast should both speak
and cause that as many would not worship
the image of the beast should be killed
bottom line if you don't go along with
the system you have no right to exist
you either obey or you're toast
that's right that's what it says in
simple language
so let's jump to revelation 17 verse 12
and the ten horns which thou sourced are
ten kings
which have received no kingdom as yet
but receive power as kings one hour with
the beast
so these powers ten horns always reminds
us of the roman empire that was divided
into ten whether this is now the
regional ten
regions of the world or whether this
refers to
that central core of what remains of the
roman empire
they had severed all relations with the
beast and became secular powers
independent of rome
but now it says
that they will receive power as kings
one hour with the beast so there's going
to be an alliance
they're going to form an alliance
so the political entities will form an
alliance with rome correct that's what
it says
so we have to look is there any movement
in that direction
and then
it says in verse 13 and they have one
mind
in other words they've drunken of the
wine of babylon they've become
indoctrinated to believe
that that which rome says is legal is
also lawful where in fact it's not
lawful it's only legal
if that makes any sense
and shall give their power and strength
unto the beast
so all these powers
will give their power unto the beast and
the one that plays a very prominent role
is the united states of america the
second beast of revelation chapter 13
and they have one mind
they have adopted the mindset of the
first piece yes that's what the bible
says will happen
and that's what we're going to look at
now how do you achieve this
because the reformation
totally destroyed that system
and it was like humpty dumpty that had
fallen off the wall and all the king's
men and all the kings horsemen and
everybody couldn't put humpty together
again
but they've been working with some super
glue yeah because they did
get it
back together if they got humpty back
together again yes so how did they how
did they do this it must be by deception
yes because the bible says you were
deceived okay so we have to think about
all of these things
and if you think of matthew what jesus
when they said what would be the sign of
your coming and all of this the first
thing he said is
careful be careful lest you be deceived
yes now it always fascinates me that the
religious leaders of the world don't see
the deception
and as soon as you try and tell them
there's a deception they climb on the
conspiracy bandwagon just like all these
speeches that we've been hearing lately
over the news
always
seem to push that button right yeah okay
come to think of it
then they can just as well say
what we've just read of revelation is
conspiratorial absolutely
it's not the bible is not conspiratorial
the bible is the word of god
revelation chapter 18 we're not going to
go through the whole thing but
we've done it many many times but just
for clarity's sake for this discussion
and after these things i saw another
angel come down from heaven having great
power and the earth was lighted with his
glory and he cried mightily with a
strong voice saying babylon the great is
fallen is fallen
he's become the habitation of devils on
the hold of every foul
spirit and a cage of every unclean and
hateful bird that's not a good
description of the spiritual
condition of the church right
for all nations
how many nations
all
have drunk of the wine of the wrath of
her fornication so they've come
into harmony with a mindset
they have one mind right
and who is of one mind the kings of the
earth
have committed fornication with the
leaders the leaders
and the merchants of the earth are waxed
rich through the abundance of our
delicacies so there's the economy
involved yes and
uh the political system is involved yes
and they are in harmony with whom
the beast the best the big businesses
this is part of the lord cry message of
revelation chapter 18.
so
if we can
see
that there is an alliance between the
kings and the merchants with the beast
then alarm bells should be ringing right
correct
i'm so stunned
that we don't hear the alarm bells
from the hierarchies of the world's
churches
and i heard another voice from heaven
saying come out of my people that ye be
not partakers of our sins and that you
receive not of her plagues have nothing
to do with this system
all right now
martin
if this is so
is this a minority that is going along
with the beast or is this a majority
well it says all nations have drunk so
this is a majority
aha
so when you hear a majority rhetoric
should you
say wow this is the truth because it's
coming from the majority or should you
investigate very closely investigate
very closely sure
when the mainstream runs with something
you must be wary you must be wary there
could be something wrong with it right
i've been listening to a couple of
really wonderful speeches some of them
more than an hour
long and you're wondering who is the
author of that speech because that same
speech will be on other airwaves in
other countries as well
with a word tweaked here and a word
tweaked there but you know anything
contrary to it is conspiratorial
all right verse 8 says therefore shall
her plagues come in one day death and
mourning and famine
and she shall be utterly burnt with fire
for strong as the lord god who judges
her
do you think it's worthwhile warning the
world for such a judgment to come yeah
or against such a judgment to come
definitely
and the kings of the earth who have
committed fornication and lived
deliciously with her
oh most of them quite wealthy
yep
do we have a couple of millionaires in
billionaires who are now ruling in in
world empires
they shall bewail and lament her
when they shall see the smoke of a
burning standing a far off for the fear
of atonement saying alas alas the great
city babylon that mighty city for in one
hour is thy judgment come and the
merchants of the earth shall weep and
mourn over
their system is going to be destroyed
yes
so if they are working together with
rome
in order to set up their system
it is a system built on sand it's going
to be destroyed
so would it be wise to learn this lesson
before the destruction or would it be
better to learn it after the destruction
after you're going to be wailing with
him you're going gonna be wailing all
right so
so this is not this is not mean-spirited
to expose these things it is an attempt
to make people aware of where we're
standing in the stream of time right and
it's a call it's a call
now here's an interesting statement that
comes from
uh spirit of prophecy volume four
and it says the aim of the great rebel
has ever been to justify himself and to
prove the divine government responsible
for the rebellion
master of reversal right he twists
everything around exactly
to this end he has bent all the powers
of his giant intellect
are we dealing with a full ear or with a
giant intellect a giant intellect giant
intellect
he has worked deliberately and
systematically
and with marvelous success
leading
vast multitudes to accept his version of
the great controversy which has been so
long in progress
okay let's think about that
so if everything looks disjointed and
chaotic
does that sound like deliberate
systematic
marvelous success no
so the chaos must be planned correct
and the order that he wants to achieve
out of that chaos must also be planned
yes and that is what will look marvelous
and
and magnificent now let's continue
for thousands of years this chief of
conspiracy
has palmed off falsehood for truth
uh my question to you martin if this
statement happens to be true
is there a conspiracy
yes
so anyone who denies that there is a
conspiracy and is constantly complaining
about people talking about conspiracy
whose side are they on
on
the conspirator side
of the great rebel right yes
the one that
brings in this controversy okay so the
initiator yeah
so perhaps we should just tell our
brethren
to please
mind their peace and cues when they
accuse people too rapidly of being
conspiratorial
because they might just be standing on
the side of the great rebel
because here it says this chief of
conspiracy has palmed of falsehood for
truth
and then it in the context of what
happens in the final restoration it says
he will be exposed
and he will be become the object of
universal abhorrence
right at the end right when it's too
late for everyone when everyone has been
wailing so is there a conspiracy
definitely yes there is a conspiracy
does the bible say there's a conspiracy
does this confirm there's a spirit
conspiracy yes yes
and are we being palmed
off with falsehood rather than truth yes
yes
here's another interesting statement
under the leadership of satan there are
men who today are doing all in their
power to plunge the world into
commercial strife
this is the economy not not the religion
yeah so we're going to have religious
turmoil and we're going to have
commercial turmoil economic so can we
expect commercial turmoil yes
does the bible say that didn't we just
read it in revelation chapter 18. so
this is perfectly in harmony with the
bible right thus satan is trying to
bring about a condition of things that
will make the world uncivilized
we haven't seen anything like that in
the news lately right
yeah
he desires to see strange things acted
out which god who is too wise to uh has
not ordained
but the lord yes our god will be ruler
of heaven and earth
if men and women will carry out his
requirements it will be seen that he is
ruler
carrying out his divine will
so when we see the chaos
god is permitting it
why to expose this great enemy correct
he's giving him enough rope yes
to hang himself but unfortunately people
believe that they can cling to that rope
so all right there will be commercial
strife
can we expect economic turmoil yes
definitely
now here's another statement which will
upset many people
and perhaps one should read it in the
entire context but it will be very long
so we'll
just leave it as it is
and try and explain what the context is
it was not the purpose of god that
poverty should ever leave the world
so is god the author of poverty then no
no
satan is the author of poverty yes but
god permitted it
and god said okay
let's leave it at that because people
can learn lessons from that
so if you are super selfish and super
rich
then you are not doing the will of god
because that's what god says you must
take care of the widows and the orphans
and you must be
uh kind and if your brother is hungry
must give him something to eat so it
brings up
benevolence or it should bring out
benevolence right
on the other hand if you are poor should
you carry
uh a grudge and go on to the bandwagons
or whatever so there are lessons to be
learnt on both sides
the ranks of society were never to be
equalized for the diversity of
conditions which characterizes our race
is one of the means by which god has
designed to prove and develop character
many have urged with great enthusiasm
that all men should have an equal share
in the temporal blessings of god
let's stop there
is there a move to
equalize
everything yep to level the playing
field yes
who's behind that movement the roman
catholic church okay according to the
statement is it in the order of god or
is it not no
okay
so catholic social doctrine says we need
to level the playing fields and
everybody should have a universal income
and possess nothing nothing
but this was not the purpose of the
creator
simple
christ has said that we shall have the
poor always with us the poor as well as
the rich or the purchase of his blood
and amongst his professed followers in
most cases the former serve him with
singleness of purpose that's the
poor while the latter are constantly
fastening their affections on their
earthly treasures and christ is
forgotten
so god could have prevented that by
saying okay let's make everybody equal
yes but would you develop character then
no
the cares of this life and the greed for
riches eclipse the glory of the eternal
world
it would be the greatest misfortune that
has ever befallen mankind
if all were to be placed upon an
equality in worldly positions
that is the exact opposite
of what
they are planning in the world today
and which is part of the great reset yes
this is the exact opposite inclusive
capitalism
you've coined the phrase or no you have
quoted the coined phrase inclusive
capitalism
fascinating
all right
now
let's go a little bit deeper
we were talking in the beginning about
legal and lawful
and uh legal language how can something
appear
so lawful when it is not
and yet it is legal yes doesn't make
any sense unless unless you dig and and
try and you know get to the root of the
matter
now there are some interesting
web pages that we you could
look at
here's one www let god be true.com bible
scripture etc
and the heading is do we need thee and
thou thy and thine in the bible
now the new translations say no let's do
away with that that's archaic right
we've discussed this before
but for the sake of completeness let's
just look at it
it says in the bible in nehemiah 8 8 so
they read in the book of the law of god
distinctly
and gave the sense
and caused them to understand the
reading
so how must you read your bible
carefully right exactly meticulously
so you look at the law of god distinctly
you have to find out what the sense is
and you must understand what you're
reading it's very important
then it says in proverbs 35 and 6 every
word of god is pure
add thou not unto his words
lest he reprove thee
and thou be found a liar
don't change god's words
don't take things out
don't add things
that's a very important thing
now when you look at
the receive text and it's so thick and
you look at the modern ones and the
words have been reduced
then you wonder this is one thing i
would like to mention here because now
that we're on this point
in the previous what's up prof
you did the one about the nephilim yes
and just there
to see the problems that new
translations has
caused
just on that point because in all the
new translations
they say
that the
heavenly
beings had relations relations with the
women of exactly and it doesn't say that
in the king james
so based on the new translations you
people say this all the all the time i i
just had a question i mean we're aware
of topic now but nevertheless i just had
a question yesterday
by someone who was complaining bitterly
and saying that cain
was
because eve had relations with the devil
but the bible clearly says and adam knew
his wife and she bore cain
it was the son of adam
so
all of these confusions come when you
change god's word great
this verse men shall not live by bread
alone but by every word of god luke
chapter 4 verse 4. so we have to be very
meticulous
now the devil wants to be like the most
high so he's very meticulous
and he uses his giant intellect
confuse the issue
because he wants to blame god and he
wants people to see it in his light so
he wants things to be legal but not
lawful yes because he hates god's law
so if you love the words of god this
author writes please take a few minutes
to delight in his precision and accuracy
in giving you the holy scripture in the
english language
the blessed god promised to preserve his
word psalms 12 67 if the lord jesus
christ was concerned about every jot
smallest hebrew letter and title hebrew
mark then surely was concerned about the
pronouns he chose for the bible
matthew 5 18.
there is a bible version far more
accurate than any others and it requires
these and those yet it is these archaic
words that are the most popular reason
for modern bible versions
take it out right we've discussed this
before but we're talking about the great
reset
we've got a
long introduction here
give you an example of how
a comma can make a difference
this man said the judge is a fool
who's the fool here
the judge aha
or this sentence here woman without a
man would be a savage
dangerous
now consider the same sentence with
punctuations
this man comma said the judge is a fool
who is now the fool this man this man
woman
hyphen without her
man would be a savage yeah so no man is
a savage
we'll stick with that okay so does
punctuation make a difference definitely
okay
and if you put the punctuation in the
wrong place could that cause a problem
yes
so legal documents
don't
have punctuation if they are high court
legal documents documents
you have to determine from the context
who the parties
are
that are being referred to
no commas
so let's take the classic example in the
bible
jesus says on that particular day
he says verily verily i say unto you
today you will be with me in heaven
now that comma is there
very i say unto you comma today you will
be within me in heaven then that day you
will be with him in heaven but at the
resurrection he tells mary i have not
yet been to heaven so he couldn't have
been there right
so if the comma is in that place then
you have a problem but whereas if the
comma was in another place and it's a
verily verily i say unto you today comma
you will be with me in heaven
then it doesn't have to be that day so
the comma is important
so if you leave the comma out completely
then both are a possibility yes so now
you read context now you have to take
the context and he said i have not yet
been to heaven then you know where the
comma should go right but if there has
been a
presupposition and someone put the karma
in people will become confused
right yes so legal documents normally
don't have a comma
and they have to be they use archaic
language
so that you know whether you're talking
to a singular person or to a plural
person now what does this got to do with
a great reset everything
because according to what we've studied
everything is a lie
the great deceiver has used his great
intellect
to make everybody believe that you have
to go along with the morality of the
beast
so how do we do that you can't just turn
it upside down
okay now here is the document
memorandum of law on the name
and many people are involved in diligent
research concerning the use of all
capital letters for proper names
for example john paul jones in capital
letters
now
this is very
interesting and we don't have to go into
all the details
but basically every language has very
specific rules and regulations as to
their use
and your name is normally written with
your first letter capitalized and the
rest in lower case
so i would be capital w
lowercase alter which makes water
and then a capital v and the rest would
be in lowercase and that would be the
way in which you spell it
now
if you change it
it has a different meaning
totally different meaning
if you even today if you use capitals in
a text message you're screaming
streaming yeah yes it has a different
connotation
so
what legal reason do they have for
changing it
they've actually created another entity
but we'll get it to that so
grammar rules the experts they all admit
that
there is no
grammatical reason why you should change
a name like this
and this person writes law is extremely
precise every letter
capitalization punctuation mark etc in a
legal document
is utilized for a specific reason and
has legal that is deadly force
consequences if for instance when
attempts to file articles of
incorporation in the office of a
secretary of the state of a state
it is the exact title of the corporation
down to every jot and title is if it's
not exactly the same each and every time
the corporation is referenced in the
documents to be filed
the secretary of state will refuse to
file the papers it has to be precise
this is because each time the name of
the corporation is referenced it must be
set forth identically
in order to express the same legal
entity
the tiniest difference in the name of
the corporation identifies an entirely
different
legal person
now it's interesting that they use the
word person we've discussed that before
persona
which means a sound sauna is a sound
that's where you get the word sonic and
all of that we've discussed that before
as well
but it also means a mask
so when you are putting on a mask
you are actually representing someone
else
it's not you
you have become someone else
now it's interesting that the government
at your birth has already created
another persona
who is not you
who is not the free man
but the bond man yeah
again now the bible we saw that in the
beginning we discussed this
now we're getting a little bit uh deeply
deeper into it and i hope i'm not boring
you no i love this okay so there is a
persona
and the sauna is an entity who is really
someone else a straw man yeah
and he has a mask on
so by wearing a mask you are already
implying that you are not who you are
uh
let's not talk about viruses yet this is
just
purely is something the way it is so if
an actor acts the role
and he has a mask on he is presenting
someone else
right okay
so the tiniest difference
makes
a massive difference
it is therefore an
eminently valid and possibly crucial
question as to why governments
governmental courts and agencies
purporting to exist in some
unidentified
unproved manner within the jurisdiction
of this state insist on always
capitalizing every letter in a proper
name
and then you have all the grammar here
and you have all the legal language and
what english grammar reference books say
and they all support this idea we're not
going to go through all of this people
can look at it for themselves it's a
fascinating
document and u.s government style and
manual and everything is hidden here in
legal language now what is the purpose
of all of this
now there's something in the law which
is called legal fiction have you heard
of legal fiction no
okay
so the real life dictionary of the law
the authors of the real life dictionary
of the law gerald and kathleen hill
are accomplished scholars and writings
and gerald hill is an experienced
attorney judge law instructor and here's
how the term legal fiction is described
it is a presumption of fact assumed by a
court for convenience
consistency orto
akiva justice
that is an old adage fictions arise from
the law and not law from fictions
still confusing right yes
let's get another definition
here is oran's dictionary of the law
illegal fiction is an assumption that
something that is or may be false or
non-existent is true or real that's a
legal fiction
so something that doesn't exist actually
exists
legal fictions are assumed or invented
to help do justice for example bringing
a lawsuit
to throw a non-existent john doe of your
property
used to be the only way to establish a
clear right to the property when legal
title was uncertain
does that make sense and yeah all right
so it is a fictitious entity yes and you
have to have that if they don't know who
the guy is correct so now
when
you were born
they created a
legal fiction
a straw man
who is a corporate identity yes but
isn't really you now this isn't
conspiracy for those who are uninformed
on these issues this is a fact
all right
so here you have merriam-webster's
dictionary of the law and i'm not going
to read all this i mean there's pages
and pages of it
so people can read it for themselves
once you get into this it gets very very
interesting because it affects
the state
which can also become a legal fiction by
getting another identity
and it affects the individual
now let's have a look at the state this
is very interesting
abraham lincoln establishes an executive
order
what are executive orders now you
remember donald trump loved executive
orders and joe biden has said he will
sign many executive orders when he
becomes president yes
85 years after the ep independence of
the united states seven southern nation
states of america walked out of the
second session
of the 36th congress on march 27 1861.
in so doing the constitutional due
process quorum
necessary for congress to vote was lost
and and congress was adjourned cine or
without day
that means it was a journey it was no
longer a legal entity because there was
no quorum
and the constitution says there has to
be a quorum so there was no government
anymore
this meant that there was no lawful
quorum to set a specific day and time to
reconvene
which according to robert's rules of
order dissolved congress
this dissolution automatically took
place because there are no provisions
within the constitution allowing the
passage of any congressional vote
without a quorum of the states
there was no more government
so what did they do
lincoln's second executive order of
april
1861 called congress back into session
days later
but not under the lawful authority
or lawful due process of the
constitution couldn't be done there was
no quorum
so solely in his capacity as
commander-in-chief of the u.s military
lincoln called congress into session
under authority of martial law
since april of 1861 congress has not
met based on lawful due process
the current contra congress is a legal
fiction
now you understand where we're going yes
based on nothing more meritorious than
yay so what are you going to do about it
having a monopoly on the currency law
and what passes for government
and most of the world's firepower the
motto of the powers that be is
we've got what it takes to take what
you've
got so the government
is a legal fiction
it is legal
but it's not lawful
are you with me yes
so now you've set up a system
that is not lawful
but operates because it's legal yeah
okay
let's continue
so there are many legal fiction laws
which justify war etc you can interfere
in any process
if you work like this
every president of the united states
since lincoln has functioned by
executive orders
issued from a military martial law
jurisdiction with only law being the law
of necessity
that is war powers that's how they
operate
the war powers are nothing new indeed
they have been operational from the
instant the first man thought that he
would hide from god
try to cheat ethical and natural law by
overreaching invade the space and
territory of others covet other people's
land or property
steal the fruits of their labor and
attempt to succeed in life by win-lose
games
all existing authority in the united
states today derives exclusively from
war powers
it's a legal fiction yeah
and everybody thinks
it is lawful no it's not it's legal
truman's reaffirmation of the
operational authority under the war
powers begins
now therefore i harry s truman president
of the united states of america acting
under and by virtue of the authority
vested in me by section 5b
of the trading with the enemy act you
see that it's martial law yeah
of october 6
1917-40 statute 415 as amended section
5b of appendix to title 50 and section 4
of the act of march 9 1993
comma 48 statute two
uh sick transit rights substance truth
justice peace and freedom in america the
land of the free and the home of the
brave
so he's taken the power
but
legally only
not lawfully yeah and under martial it's
not according to
the constitution
so now basically what that means
that what has been happening in politics
is to a very large degree a sharad
a charade if you want to pronounce it
that way
and
therefore
we could go further into this but now we
have to first look at the individuals
i'm going to go down this applies to all
the states as well they have the same
thing
the present situation in america a legal
person equals a legal fiction what does
that mean
one of the terms used predominantly by
the present civil government and courts
in america is legal person
just what is a legal person
some definitions are
a legal person is a body of persons
or an entity as a corporation
considered as having many of the rights
and responsibilities of a natural person
and especially the capacity to sue and
be sued miriam webster's dictionary of
the law
so you can be a legal person and
actually be a corporation
not be a person at all you can be a
straw man
and that's exactly what the world has
done with you
and this is how the economics of the
world works and that is why we have to
understand it to some extent it is so it
is so
huge that you know it will take a
lifetime of study to get to the base of
it
but
basically
governments and individuals
can be the real
issue the real thing or a fictional
issue
and there can be both
so if you have the united states of
america as a sovereign nation
anybody living in that nation is a free
man if he is born there and wouldn't be
subject to anything any payments you
with me yeah
but if you register that same united
states of america as a corporation in
another country
then it is a foreign entity
are you worth it yes
if you take the individual and you link
him to the foreign company the united
states of america
corporation but still it says united
then you're also a foreigner because
you're registered in a foreign entity
and you must pay taxes
because the foreigner pays taxes
so in other ways the devil
is playing the legal game
but he's not lawful yes he's exploiting
you correct now how does he do this this
is
amazing
now martin let's just get to the
individual so we've seen that
governments
are either lawful but they can also be
legal which doesn't mean that they're
lawful yeah let's look at the individual
since the early 1960s is talking about
the united states of america but it's
the same for every country in the world
yes
state governments themselves especially
created juristic corporate persons
signified by all caps
if you take your credit card the name is
written in all caps
if it were written with a uppercase
rest lowercase wording which is the
correct one
it would be the credit card of the
natural person yes but because it's
written in caps it's the credit card of
the corporate person the straw man that
doesn't really exist that legal fiction
that legal fiction
so
themselves specially created juristic
corporate persons signified by all caps
have issued birth certificates to
persons now remember you can have this
sauna this mass
and
not be the real you
with legal fiction all caps names this
is not a lawful record of your physical
birth but rather the birth of the
juristic or cap's name
it may appear to be your true name but
since no proper name is ever written in
all caps either lawfully or
grammatically
it does not identify who you are the
birth certificate is the government's
self-created document of title for its
new property
that is the deed of the juristic name
artificial person
whose all cap
name mirrors your true name
it mirrors it mirrors yeah it is an
image
yes the birth certificate brings the new
all caps name into colorable admiralty
maritime law the same way a ship
and ship of state is birthed so you have
become an entity and you don't belong
to
yourself you belong to the government
yes that's legal fiction of you that's
the legal fiction that they created now
and then you go to the hospital and you
actually
give your date of birth they give a name
and your parents give a name and your
weight is recorded we'll come to that in
a moment i don't know if you're going to
mention it but come to think of it
you mentioned the bank your credit card
yes if it was
under the capital
uh first letter the normal the legal
the lawful person yes they were they
could not charge you any interest they
wouldn't be able to charge your interest
no because that would be usury correct
there is actually a way to go about it
but they've stopped most of those courts
there are still some courts where you
could fight to get back your
real identity which has been stolen
at birth without you knowing it
so it says here it is not difficult to
see that a state-created birth
certificate with an all-caps name
is a document evidencing debt the moment
it is issued
once a state has registered a birth
document with the united states
department of commerce the department
notifies the treasury department
which takes out a loan from the federal
reserve
the treasury uses the loan to purchase a
bond
the fed holds a purchase money security
interest in the bond
now martin
this might all seem
disjointed and disconnected but this is
the crux of the matter
this is the the fiction that has been
created
this falsehood that is peddled as truth
this is the devil's strategy
it is amazing yeah
and it is legal
but it is not lawful yeah who do you
belong to to god
did he purchase you yes did he pay a
high price for you yeah with his blood
so does anyone have the right to create
an entity out of you no
all right let's go and read this
carefully from the beginning
it is not difficult to see that the
state-created birth certificate with an
all-caps name is a document evidencing
debt the moment it is issued okay
once the state has registered the birth
document with the united states
department of commerce
the department notifies the treasury
department
which takes out a loan from the federal
reserve
so every time someone is born
you send in the application
and a few days later
you get the birth certificate
if you take one out in this country
the reserve bank is on it yes and you
ask yourself the question excuse me what
is the reserve bank got to do with my
birth certificate right yeah
so the same here you are people
they bought you it's an entity no
so they take out a loan the treasury
uses the loan to purchase a bond
and then the fed holds a purchase money
security interest in the bond or any
reserve bank
in any country
will do the same yeah that's how the
monetary system has been syndrome
okay now what happens then
from the department of commerce which
invests the sale proceeds in the stock
or bond market
so now this money
that has been given from the fed or from
a reserve bank to the government
is invested in the stock exchange
and anybody can trade with that name
with that bond no
so you have become an entity on the
stock market
and people can invest in that bond
because it is tradable and it can become
worth millions yeah
so even if you are a useless person in
society you still have generated a huge
amount of money now in actual fact
how much money
it's interesting
that your weight is recorded
and it's normally recorded in ounces and
pounds yeah
and the gold standard is also in ounces
and pounds
and in actual fact the amount of money
that is set aside at your birth is your
exact gold worth in weight in weight
have you ever heard the
the statement batman is worth his weight
in gold
well this is literally the case
so you are born actually very wealthy
according to the system yeah but let's
continue
the treasury department then issue
issues treasury securities in the forms
of treasury bonds
notes and bills
using the bonds as surety for the new
securities
this also
means that the bankrupt corporate usa
because the usa is actually bankrupt
can guarantee to the purchasers of their
security the lifetime labor and tax
revenue of every citizen of the united
states of america with the birth
certificates is collateral for payment
so you've become collateral yeah
but even if you never pay taxes you've
already generated money on the stock
exchange yes
and from the bond and by your weight
isn't that fascinating
very
this device is initiated simply by
converting the lawful true name of the
child into a legal heuristic name
of a person so when the bible says every
bond man and every free man
we're all bond men except those
that are free men
and they don't have to pay taxes
i'm wondering
which of the high flyers don't have to
pay taxes
let's read on legally you are considered
to be a slave or
indentured servant to the various
federal state and local governments via
your state issued and state-created
birth certificate in the name of your
all caps person
and that is linked directly
to the banking system yes because that's
where the money flows that's why all
your
transactions whatever you purchase
whatever you do
is always in capitals
and you sign it yes with your signature
yes so then you take responsibility for
it but the signature
is not you as a free person the
signature belongs to the straw person
because
if it was really you it wouldn't be a
signature it would be an autograph
okay when you go to a superstar do you
say please give me your signature yeah
no you're talking to the real person you
say may i have your autograph
can you see how important language is
yes
and that's why
the language and the bible yeah becomes
so important it is so very precise
like i said verily verily i say unto
thee
ye
must be born again the thee is
addressing the individual the free man
the ye is addressing everyone if that is
not in there it is dubious exactly so
how dubious can it
become you're in a court of law
and the judge wants to find
you
responsible for
a outstanding
debt whatever that is
right
and he says i find you
he's guilty
well then you should ask him
thine honor
to which of the plurality of you are you
referring to because you is plural
it's just become
singular or plural in the day-to-day
language but legally you is plural
so then i have to say
to which of the plurality of individuals
are thee referring to
to the free man
or to the straw man yes
the legal fiction the legal fiction
now the one who owes the money is always
the legal fiction because you signed
with your signature signature now what
if you never signed
then then you don't have a contract
correct
and somebody who is a legal fiction
doesn't exist so they could never force
you to pay it right but they do because
they can get away with it legally but
not lawfully yes
are we confusing everybody
i hope they're keeping up because
i'm i'm still keeping up so i'm
confusing myself
but this is how it works yeah
and also
the very words you use are very
important a representative shall we
appoint a representative for you
that means you're appointing someone
else
now
when you put pen to paper with your
signature who's got the pen in his hand
you you have yes the free man the free
man what are you signing
on behalf of the
the legal legal fiction yes all right so
now you've signed on behalf of the legal
fiction
so you become surety for the legal
so if the legal fiction
becomes guilty of something
the one who has signed surety is the one
who goes to jail yes
right yeah if you borrow money from the
bank and your father signed surety for
you and you refuse to pay you're the one
in the wrong but he's but he's the one
that goes to jail yes same here yes so
the legal fiction is guilty of not
paying xyz
therefore the surety goes to jail which
is the free man yes
so what you should say to the judge is
which of the two you are you finding
guilty here
because
i the free man
refused to stand in for the straw man
then honor i appoint thee to represent
the straw man who goes to jail then
he goes
he goes to jail so he would better throw
the case out than to go on with it but
this becomes you know
yes it becomes a game yeah it becomes a
game so let's read what it says here
legally
you are considered to be a slave or
indentured servant to various federal
state and local governments via your
state issued and state-created birth
certificate
in the name of your all-caps person
birth certificates are issued
so that the issuer can claim exclusive
title to the legal person created
thereby so the government owns you
this is further compounded when one
voluntarily obtains a driver's license
or a social security account number
the state even owns your personal and
private life through your state issued
marriage license certificate issued in
the all caps name
you have no rights in birth marriage or
even death yeah nothing the state holds
title to all legal persons the state
creates via birth certificates until the
rightful owner ieu
reclaims redeems it by becoming the
holder in due course of the instrument
you can fight a legal battle to get your
free man status back
and then everything would have to be
transferred to you you would probably
have to pay for that
and has to be written in the non-caps
form in order to be legally yours
so who owns everything
well the question is
who do the corporations belong to
because they're registered somewhere
now under whose auspices are they
registered
they're registered under the crown
okay no matter where you are in the
world
the the british empire was everywhere
they registered under the crown
so the crown possesses the land you may
live in the house on your property you
may pay the taxes
but if you forfeit it
the the land belongs to the crown
but didn't you do a lecture in showing
that the crown belongs to rome
that is very important that we know that
because historically
the crown was seeded to rome so rome
actually owns
everything
and that has never been rescinded
because the crown of the queen or the
king of england was put back on her or
his head
only
unconditionally yes they they
burrowing or or
leasing it or they
releasing it from the real owner yeah
and which is wrong
now uh that lecture was called the
beamable sustainable princess
that was a very old lecture of mine
but in any case this is this is all very
fascinating stuff yeah now that but this
like what you just
told us now and linking with that yeah
it just makes so much sense but now
we're going to cut get into we still
have to get into what's happening in the
world right and the recess this is the
introduction
okay
so
let's just
get this straight governments get their
money how
through your birth yes how did they get
it before
it was upon the gold standard right
right but all governments are bankrupt
yes and therefore they have no gold
who has the gold then
the crown the one who has
the and it's the crown and who owns the
crown
wrong church all right so all
governments are bankrupt
every single
one
and the money that is flowing in the
economy is based on your straw man
that's the economy and that's the worth
of the economies of the world today now
congress still convening strictly under
executive order authority confirmed the
bankruptcy through the joint resolution
to the spend the gold standard and
abrogate the gold clause june 5 1933
so since then they're all bankrupt yeah
and they have loans based on the straw
men yeah that they have created
which
initiate a bond which is traded on the
stock exchange
okay
we don't have to go
into any more detail
so since 1933 the only assets used by
the united states to pay its debt to the
fed have been the blood sweat and tears
of every american unfortunate to be
settled with a birth certificate and a
social security number
that's how they pay their debts
and that's why they continue going
and the debt can increase and increase
and increase but at some stage the
bubble
must
burst yes
that's our introduction
so now we can actually say what is going
to happen in the great reset yes
so let's just briefly summarize
all governments are actually
corporations
all individuals are actually
belonging to those governments yes
and all of the actual
possessions
are
the owner are the property of the crown
yes
and the crown owned is owned by rome
so all roads lead to rome the entire
world economy
is linked to rock
and if we understand that we can see why
all the kings of the world and all the
merchants of the world have no other way
of dealing with issues other than
through
rome yes okay
so what we have established is that the
systems of government
and commerce
are
so interlinked that they cannot be
separated
where the one goes the other one goes
the banking system
is involved at every level
and
the powers that be the crown eventually
roam
in the ultimate hiding behind the crown
they always have front organizations
are the real owners of everything of
everything
that's how it works
now
once all of these
systems have become corrupted
and once the divide between rich and
poor has become so great that it's no
longer sustainable and once the debt has
accumulated to such an extent that it
can no longer be repaid
then there must be a crash yes
and the question we have to ask
ourselves is where are we in the stream
of time
and how do the issues that are taking
place in the world now fit into this
picture
and how does it fit into the prophetic
picture yes
we've established that everything is
based on a legal basis which is not
lawful yes and that's how the devil
works
and he's using his great intellect to
bring about a system
where the first beast will be honored
again
as it was honored before the mortal
wound yes only now on a universal scale
and this is what prophecy is all about
and we are at the very
tip of the toes of daniel
and we must now look at the great reset
and look at what the economists are
saying and what the world economic forum
is saying and what the papacy is saying
and people have no idea that the papacy
is behind it all no but that is what
prophecy tells us yes and that is why we
must show them how it is interconnected
and then they will hopefully understand
what
comprises babylon not only the religious
entities but the political
and the economic issues as well yeah
hopefully that can can put some
sense in everything that's happening
because now every all this is happening
you've got this financial problems or
economic problems and all this now if
you have
a clear understanding of how you have
been duped
wouldn't you want to separate from the
system
at least spiritually and intellectually
even if you cannot do it physically but
at least you know at least you know and
that is what we want to discuss
in part two so now we'll get to the real
nitty-gritty of what has been happening
and why it has been happening let's pray
heavenly father
this issue is so large
that
nobody
will ever to fully comprehend
what is happening
it will take eternity to unravel all the
intricacies we are dealing with a great
intellect
of a great enemy
of the government of god
and god is calling his people
to follow the word and the word only and
even here he has managed to bring in so
much deception
that people cannot recognize the
covenant of god for what it is
give us insight and understanding is my
prayer in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe
click here
when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here
thank you